Hey, Cook this guy. Yeah. Cook this guy.
AI. How you doing? Good. He's saying his
multiple Qurans. You're a Muslim? Yeah,
I am Muslim. Awesome. Awesome. Awesome.
One second. I'm going to get my guy to
cook you real quick. Oh, you got a guy.
What's this guy saying, though? Guys,
his name is Guy Logic. Are you a
supporter? No, he's saying there's
multiple Qurans, bro. Bro, are you
crazy, brother? You're saying there's
multiple Qurans? We're not just saying
it. We got him. No, he's he's actually
like a he's a Christian guy, brother.
There's only one Quran and it's never
been changed and never will be changed.
Can you see the screen? Where you're
bringing this false accusations from?
Hey yo, can you see the screen? Okay,
that's from people who are trying to
people who are trying to create false
Qurans and false. Wait, those are false
Qurans, bro. False Qurans and nobody
reads them, brother. Nobody reads those
false Qurans. Garbage. Garbage. Wow. So,
you just called Allah's word garbage,
brother. You bring that to the mosque,
they're not even going to put it on the
shelf. Yo, let me tell you one thing.
Let me tell you one thing. Let me tell
you one says before if I go if I go and
change a word in the Bible, is anyone
going to correct me before you move on?
Do you even know what those Quran say?
No. Before we move before we move on, if
I change a word from every chapter in
the Bible, is anyone going to know? Ask
me that question, please. Yes, of
course, we're going to know. We're going
to know, brother. We will all know. So,
if we change anything, any word, we
change any word from the Quran, will
will we know? If we change a word from
the Quran, memorize the Quran and they
know it by heart. Everyone can hear
every book. Guys, can you can you guys
hear us? I can hear you. I can hear you
over there. Okay. It sounds like we're
we're all talking at the same time.
Let's make sure one we talk one at a
time. So, you said yes. If somebody
changed a word in your Quran, we'd know.
Of course. How would you know, bro? You
know, in Eid when during prayer, if the
if the the im screws up, you have 50
people correcting him in the back. Okay.
And how do you know that that they're
correct? That they're correcting him on
the right reading cuz they
never because the Quran has never been
changed for 1,400 years. Never been
changed. Not even once. What does mean
different recitations? Oh, different
recitations. Oh, that's it. So, wait.
So, you guys just Hold on, hold on. So,
are the different recitations are they
from Allah? What do you like? What do
you mean? Are the different recitations
from Allah?
recitations. The only reason there's
different different recitations is
because there was different dialects. I
know. I know you guys are fumbling on
this question though. But are these
different recitations? Are these
different dialects? Are they from Allah
or not? Of course. Yes, they are from
Allah because why did you why did you
just say that they're garbage then when
when when God let show you them because
you're saying this is they're not
changing the words. They're not changing
nothing people pronounce it. It's only
the way it's like how a person from
England has an accent accent in Canada.
No. So are they garbage or are they
Allah's word? They're Allah's word. But
those words why do you call them
garbage? Can I ask? Can you can you hear
me out? I said any person who comes and
changes the Quran even by one letter
it's or even just one uh uh what do you
call it? How do I say you guys don't say
you know you guys don't know Arabic so I
would say
hey
say the same thing one letter everybody
knows one. Okay. So what's the
difference between Malik and Malik? Is
it a haraka or is it or what is it?
Malik. Malik is the king and Malik is
the king of all. Okay. What's the
difference? Is it af or Malik and Malik?
It's it's a No, it's not. It's not. It's
al if man. Malik has al and Malik
doesn't. So you don't know anything. So
there's actually difference with Are you
Are you Christian, brother? We're
Christian. We're Christians and we're
Arab and we we'll get you busted. Okay.
You don't know the difference between no
problem. You don't know a difference
between a haraka and and al if you think
al if is a haraka. Okay, but you get my
point. Maybe I don't I'm not Let me just
tell you one thing. I'm not I don't
Okay, can I tell you? One second. One
second. Melik and Melik. Are they
accents? No, it's different words. Thank
you. So they're not different dialects.
Not different. So you lied to us. You
said dialects. First you called me the
word. Can you show me the word? Okay.
Now, okay. Can I ask you a question? Why
are we going into Can I ask you a
question? Can I ask can I ask you bro
you know first you called Allah's words
garbage in the beginning of say
yeah but you said dialects you said
dialects and now you change it to words
so you lie why do Muslims lie so what do
you mean am I changing it to words you
said dialect different words and they're
approved from our from our lord okay our
lord is
saying when did he approve when did he
approve them give Give me aith when came
out. What do you mean? Yeah. Where where
where did he say Malik is okay and Malik
is okay? Give me a Muhammad Malik is
okay. Different different uh just give
me one second. This is take a day take
24 hours. You want to comp you want to
compare the Quran to the Bible, bro? I'm
not comparing nothing. I'm asking I'm
asking you Muhammad. I'm not comparing
the Bible. I'm asking about Muhammad.
Where did he says where did he say Malik
is okay and Melik is okay? Listen
listen. What's your what's your main
point here? I'm asking you now. I I have
a question. I have a question. I don't
care about your question. This is about
Quran. Okay. I have a question. What's
your end goal here? What's your end
goal? Like my end goal is that no one
approved it and you all made it up.
That's what what the end goal is. Your
end point is what? No, no. Just I want
to know what's your end point. Like
what's what's the argument? It's not
preserved, dude. Nobody knows where the
Quran is not preserved. You have
hundreds of millions of people that
memorize the Quran. Memorize the Bible.
There are millions of Hindus that are
wrong. So what? Listen, you can ask me
pages from the Quran. I'll give I'll
give you some research. Uh,
alhamdulillah. I wouldn't say I'm uh I'm
fully 100% memorized the Quran, but I
memorized at least 85 to 90% of the
Quran. Memorize the Bible. If somebody
opens the Bible right now, are you going
to tell me you memorized the Quran? Do
you have it memorized by heart? Can you
can you can you recite chapter 37:12 in
the Hamza? What happened? The recitation
lost in the memory. What happened?
There's two of you guys. So, if one of
you guys gets it wrong, the other one
could correct you. Can you guys recite
chapter 37:12?
They're looking it up in their memory.
They're googling it. If you guys need
the chapter name, it's uh Sarah Asafat.
Sarah Asafat ay 12. Can you recite it in
Kafanhanza? Can you guys recite it from
there? I'll uh No, he's asking them.
I'll go ahead and I'll go ahead and play
the uh play the waiting music here.
Let's try to
[Music]
You guys got it yet? You know what I
think they did? I think that cuz they're
on their phone. They like went to
another window. They don't know. We
can't hear them. Yeah. They don't know
that. No, I could hear you. I thought
No, just music came out. The music.
Somebody put on music. I don't know why.
Oh, sorry. I was It was the waiting
music. Can you guys recite Sarah? Yes. A
ayat 12. Okay. Just Just one eye or you
want me to read the whole I could do
both. Just one just one ayat. That's all
I need.
That's good. That's You want me to keep
going? That's good. No, that that's
good. So, you
said Okay. What? You're trying to put it
on me now? No. No. I'm just I'm just
asking like that's good. What What does
that translate to? In fact, you are
astonished by their denial. While they
ridicule you? You are astonished while
they mock and and and they ridicule you.
Okay, cool. So, are you are you talking
about me or are you talking about you?
What recitation did you just what
recitation did you use? Uh this is Han
Aim. Han Aasam. Okay. Do can you recite
the one from uh from uh Khalifan Hanza?
Uh to be I don't know me personally I
only know Hanum. You know my cousin you
know my cousin knows the 10
differentations of the Quran in my
heart. Do you have your cousin here? He
doesn't I don't have him here. He's back
home. He doesn't live here. But I'm
telling you he knows. And my
brother-in-law too. My brother-in-law.
My brother-in-law. If I can't talk to
your brother-in-law or your cousin, man,
bringing them up is not going to help
me. Okay, it's all good. It's all good.
It's all good. So, we got the we got the
huffs. I just heard you recite the
huffs. That's cool. Um, giant DLC, do
you guys mind pulling up? It's a shame
that you need your cousin and
brother-in-law to know what the the end
of your Quran that Allah also approved.
But anyway, I don't I'm not a she. I
don't memorize the Quran. Yeah, but you
said millions of people that But you
said millions. You said millions of name
you can't name me a single person but no
no no one second one second. You said
millions of us all all of us know it a
sentence in every chapter of the of the
Bible and you guys would not know it and
that's the difference between the two.
Oh man. Okay. So let's see you but you
still don't know it. You need your
brother-in-law though. Of course I don't
know it but I can I can I have 10 people
that do though. No no he's Yeah, but I
have 10 people that do as well. Listen
listen. Okay. Listen. His bas his b his
his basic argument his basic argument is
that the Quran could never be changed I
hear you guys see the screen I'll tell
you
this yes it depends on
the difference it can never be I had to
I had to mute you guys cuz you guys are
just in panic mode just talking way too
much let's have a structured
conversation I know you guys are excited
I know you guys are you know a little
hyped to be here and defend your
religion slow down. Let's have a logical
conversation here. So, I just heard you
recite Sir Asafat ayia 12 from Hoffs and
you I asked you to do the one from
Hamza. You said you didn't remember it
or you didn't know that you didn't you
don't know all. Okay, that's fine. I
have it on the screen. Can you see the
screen? Can you guys see the screen?
You're unmuted. Abe. Yeah, I'm still
here now. All right. Can you guys see
the screen? Can I Can I Can I explain
something to you? And we don't want to
hold us. Read the screen. We got for
you. You have hops.
Can you read the screen?
That's
what is it different? Is it different to
your Huffs? Yes, it is. But it's the
dialect. So, is the word the word
different? This is a dialect. One
second. This is a dialect change. Oh, is
the word different? What What does it
mean in your HS? What does
mean? Oh, you were okay. Surprised,
astonished, something that Okay, you are
surprised. Yes. Yes. So, how do you say
I am surprised?
Ana
anapu anat is not dialect it means oh my
god okay this is so what does it mean
now can you tell the people now that I
corrected you can you can you change it
to what it actually means the listen is
it not the same word yes or no so what
are you talking about it's not it's not
it's not the same word the
the changes it changes the pronoun It
changes from you are amazed to what I
am. You bring up where that dialect came
from. Like what part of the country is
that dialect? What country? This not a
dialect. Different in different dialects
like
Moroccan
dialect. Can you tell me how how did the
word change? The word is still there.
No, it's it's a different it's
different. All right. So, let's let's
slow this down. In English, we don't
have a Can you hear me? Can you hear me?
Abe, I can hear you. Yes. Yes. Yes, we
can hear you, brother. All right. You
said that a object apta means you were
amazed. You were astonished, right? AJ
too. What does a 2 mean?
I was I was astonished. Very good. So,
it changes from you to I, right? Yes.
Those are two different words. Can we
agree? Well, in maybe the different
dialect, that's what the word means. But
nothing changed. So So it changes. Let's
Let's see if it grants you that it's a
different dialect. Doesn't have
different accents, different dialect. So
it So it's a different word when it goes
from you to I, right? Okay. Well, is it
there some Isn't there a lot of
different languages in the world? This
is the same language and the and the way
the make the way they make sentences
sentences is different. This is the
same. This is the same language, bro.
It's Arabic. Chinese. No, it's a
different it's a different dialect. So,
it can make it the way they say a
different word is different. Yes,
because it's a different No, you hold on
a second. I need you to answer this
question, bro. I need you to answer the
question. Yes. Is it a different word if
it changes from you were astonished to I
was astonished? Does it is that a
different word? To be honest, I don't
speak the different dialects. So, in the
different dialect, it could mean the
same meaning. I'm asking you if it
says to be honest. To be honest, it
changes. To be honest, brother, to be
honest, brother, I don't know. Not I do
not know that dialect. I cannot speak.
You're not stupid. You're not stupid.
And I refuse to allow you to play
ignorant here. You're not dumb. I know
you're not dumb. It's simple, brother. I
can bring If it goes from you were
astonished to I was astonished, is that
a word change? Brother, I'm gonna bring
you somebody who knows these. Do you see
the how like the the brainwashing is
real? It's dialect dialect. There's
there's no question about this, man. You
guys enter Islam and somehow
someway words don't make sense to you.
You don't know what things mean anymore.
You don't you can't say if you versus I
is a difference. You're going to start
saying that you and I is the same exact
thing and same exact word. This is what
happens to you when you grow up or join
Islam. Grow up in Islam, join Islam
fries your brain, man. This is what
happens. Fries your brain.